We're going to go, we're going to go live in five. We're going to go. Well, let's do a quick, quick cold. Let's do a quick cold. Let's do it in five. When I get down, we're going to go cold. This is how we count down to the cold open. Right.
我们要开始了，我们要开始直播了，五秒倒计时。我们要开始了。好吧，我们来个快速的，快速的冷开场。我们来个快速的冷开场。五秒钟开始。等我准备好，我们就开始冷开场。这就是我们倒计时进入冷开场的方式。对。
Are you going to say one or you're just going to stop it two? I'm not going to say one. I'm also not going to say two. Old broadcast out. So I'm going to go five, four, three. By the way, you're wrong about that. You know, I've heard, I've heard you say that before. Everyone always says the two.
你是要数到一，还是数到二就停？我不会数一。我也不会数二。老派广播。所以我数五、四、三。顺便说一句，你那样做是不对的。你知道，我以前听你说过。每个人总是数到二。
It's just the one that's not safe. Five. Four, three. Welcome to the cold open. Welcome to Smartless. Ah. Everybody takes. Hey, everybody.
只有一是不安全的。五。四。三。欢迎来到冷开场。欢迎来到Smartless。啊。每个人都拿。嘿，大家好。
Jay, in through the nose, out through the mouth. Park. Now we start. Hi. Hi. Hey. Thanks for coming today. Hey, you want to know?
杰，用鼻子吸气，用嘴呼气。停。现在我们开始。嗨。嗨。嘿。谢谢你们今天能来。嘿，你想知道吗？
Oh, go ahead. Oh, no. Sorry. Do you have a story all queued out there? Yeah, I just actually thought of this. Our show opened last Saturday. You know, I saw you on my Instagram-ish thing. And you were saying hi to the audience
哦，你说吧。哦，不。抱歉。你是不是准备好了一个故事？是啊，我刚才突然想到了。我们的演出上周六开幕了。你知道，我在Instagram上看到你了。你当时在跟观众打招呼，
and I immediately got a little nervous. I was like, oh my God, there he is. He's on stage, he's in front of it. He did it. So you did it, you did an initial, we in previews right now? Yeah, first preview went great, second one went terrible.
我立刻就有点紧张了。我就想，天哪，他就在那儿。他在舞台上，在观众面前。他做到了。所以你做到了，你做了一个初步的，我们现在是在预演阶段吗？是的，第一次预演很棒，第二次糟透了。
I love all the photos. You look like you're standing on the, like, the bow of a boat because you're always like standing there like looking off into the distance, you know. Simon the King of the World or something. Yeah, he's proud and he's here. Hey, tell us, okay, so tell us what was good about the first and bad about the second well you'll relate you like this kind of talk this it's talking shop you know
我喜欢所有的照片。你看起来就像站在船头一样，因为你总是站在那儿，望着远方，你知道的。像世界之王什么的。是的，他很骄傲，他就在这儿。嘿，告诉我们，好吧，告诉我们第一次好在哪里，第二次坏在哪里，你会感同身受的，你喜欢这种谈话，这是在谈论行话，你知道的，
when you kind of connect to what you're saying it's very real and it's authentic right and then sometimes when you do a show up a million times you sometimes there's a little tiny veil between you and the yeah and so but you're doing the actions and you're emoting but it's a little manufactured yeah and that's how the second show was that's how the second show but i bet the audience i bet it didn't feel good but I bet it still was good. Sean, explain to the audience a little bit, because you told me that, you and I spoke earlier and you told me that.
当你和你所说的话产生连接时，它是非常真实和地道的，对吧？然后有时当你演了一百万次节目，有时你和你自己之间会有一层薄薄的面纱，是的，所以你虽然在做动作，在表达情感，但有点刻意了，是的，第二次演出就是那样，第二次演出就是那样，但我敢打赌观众，我敢打赌虽然感觉不好，但我敢打赌它依然很好。肖恩，给观众解释一下，因为你告诉过我，你和我之前聊过，你告诉过我。
And I said, well, that's to be expected. And I said that because... It's very frightening. It's kind of a known thing, right? You do your first show, and it's great. It's like gangbusters, yeah. And then there is that sort of sophomore slump. Yeah, I guess...
我说，嗯，这是意料之中的。我之所以这么说是因为……这非常可怕。这是一种众所周知的事情，对吧？你做第一次演出，非常棒。就像大获成功一样，是的。然后就会出现那种所谓的“大二综合症”。是的，我想……
I wonder if it's an energy thing. Like, oh, man, I'm exhausted, right? And then maybe that's just... I don't know. And then you kind of build back up again. Yeah, but when you're standing on the stage and you're saying the words and like your mind goes blank, but your mouth keeps talking.
我在想这是否是能量的问题。就像，天哪，我精疲力竭了，对吧？然后也许这就是……我不知道。然后你又慢慢恢复了。是的，但当你站在舞台上，说着台词，大脑一片空白，但嘴巴还在不停地说。
Right. Was it just you going through this? Or did the other actors have a good time? Was it a good show for them? How were they? Sometimes you can just rely on the rest of the team. And you know, J.B. and I and our crew were coming next week to see you. Yeah, J.B., I don't know if you know this.
对。是你一个人经历这些吗？还是其他演员玩得很开心？对他们来说这是一场好演出吗？他们怎么样？有时你可以依靠团队的其他成员。你知道，JB和我还有我们的剧组下周要去看你。是的，JB，我不知道你知不知道。
This is the best news, Sean told me today. You ready? It's an hour 15. Yeah. Oh, it's a tight hour 15. Do I get to sit front row? We're at dinner before we know it. Do I get to hold the book?
这是最好的消息，肖恩今天告诉我的。准备好了吗？是一个小时十五分钟。是的。哦，是一个紧凑的一小时十五分钟。我能坐在前排吗？我们很快就会去吃晚饭。我可以拿剧本吗？
Can I hold the book front row? Yeah. And be the guy you turn to if you forget a line? I would love that. And then I give you the wrong line. Or you just, you look to me and I just look up at you and I just give you a real polite middle finger. Yeah. If you gave J.B. the book, I would say this is a compliment.
我可以坐在前排拿剧本吗？是的。如果你忘了台词，我就是那个你可以求助的人？我很乐意。然后我给你错误的台词。或者你只是，你看着我，我抬头看着你，然后给你一个非常有礼貌的中指。是的。如果你把剧本给JB，我会说这是一种恭维。
You just give me a line from 12 in 10 minutes. Yeah. That's the way you would. Yeah. You would be really good at that. It's ridiculous. Yeah. But when those curtains open and the lights come on, you're like, oh, there's, I have to do this.
你十分钟后给我一句台词。是的。你就是那样。是的。你在这方面会非常擅长。这太荒谬了。是的。但当幕布拉开，灯光亮起，你会想，哦，天哪，我必须得做这个。
It's the scariest thing in the world. How was Scotty? Was Scotty a puddle of nerves? I bet he was. He looked scared. But you know what? He looked like he doesn't know what to do. I went to PT today physical therapy because I'm standing so long on stage.
这是世界上最可怕的事情。斯科蒂怎么样？斯科蒂是不是紧张得要命？我敢打赌他是。他看起来很害怕。但你知道吗？他看起来不知道该怎么办。我今天去做了物理治疗，因为我在舞台上站得太久了。
And so even right now, as I'm talking to you, I have to learn how to do sit-ups. Like, you know, like you- Oh, is that what they said? Engage your core. You got to engage your core. Yeah, gauge your core. PT doctors said the middle's too soft. And you're wearing double hokas, right? You've got custom double hokas on.
所以即使是现在，当我跟你说话时，我必须学习如何做仰卧起坐。就像，你知道，就像你——哦，他们是这么说的吗？调动你的核心肌群。你必须调动你的核心肌群。是的，调动你的核心。物理治疗医生说中间太软了。而且你穿着双层Hoka鞋，对吧？你穿的是定制的双层Hoka鞋。
Hey, why don't you get one of those cashier mats? Custom double hokas. Hooks him at the bottom of my shoes. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, cut out a couple of shoe size, shoe size cashier mats. Like snowboards. Yeah.
嘿，你为什么不弄个那种收银员用的垫子？定制双层Hoka。把垫子钩在我的鞋底。是的，是的。是的，剪下几块鞋码大小的收银员垫子。像滑雪板一样。是的。
That's really funny. So you've got to engage, so you're doing setups. You're trying to do exercises to engage your core. Your core, so you're back, right? You guys all know that. But I just kind of haven't been doing that. Anyway, who cares? Don't get me going on core.
那真的很有趣。所以你必须调动，所以你在做仰卧起坐。你正在尝试做运动来调动你的核心。你的核心，也就是你的背部，对吧？你们都知道。但我一直没怎么做。总之，谁在乎呢？别让我谈论核心了。
Yeah. Guys, someone who has a really good core is my guest today. Here we go. He grew up in a remote Australian community, four hours from the nearest town, spent his teenage years surfing. Fed income. And at one point, repaired breast pumps
是的。伙计们，今天我的嘉宾有一个非常好的核心。我们开始吧。他在一个偏远的澳大利亚社区长大，离最近的城镇有四个小时的路程，青少年时期都在冲浪。靠收入生活。有一次，在工厂里修理吸奶器，
in a factory for $10 an hour. He moved to L.A. to be an actor and was about to quit until one last audition, flipped the script. That's the way it always happens, isn't it? He named his son after Brad Pitt's character and Legends of the Fall, but you may know him as Captain Kirk's father.
每小时10美元。他搬到洛杉矶当演员，差点就要放弃了，直到最后一次试镜，扭转了局面。事情总是这样发生的，不是吗？他以布拉德·皮特在《燃情岁月》中的角色给儿子命名，但你可能知道他是詹姆斯·柯克船长的父亲。
It's the brilliant, charming. Chris Hemsworth. Hello. Wow. Hello. How are you? How are you? Hello, Chris.
他就是才华横溢、魅力十足的克里斯·海姆斯沃斯。你好。哇。你好。你好吗？你好吗？你好，克里斯。
Guys, this is, Chris knows my wife, okay? Oh, really? I'll leave it at that. I'll leave it at that. Well, we got to start there. You'll leave it at that and I'll pick it up from there. Chris. Wait, for real?
伙计们，这个，克里斯认识我妻子，好吗？哦，真的吗？我就说到这儿。我就说到这儿。好吧，我们得从那儿开始。你点到为止，我会接着说。克里斯。等等，真的吗？
Yeah, they've done a little bit of part. We're partying together. Oh, what is that being? Yeah. It's getting worse. Where have you been at all those parties, might? I know. You weren't involved?
是的，他们一起参加过一点派对。哦，那是什么意思？是的。情况越来越糟了。你到底去过那些派对吗，伙计？我知道。你没参与？
I'm so, you weren't allowed to come. I'm kind of jealous. Well, I lost my privileges years ago, and I think it's better for me to stay out of what we call trigger environments. I should probably do design. Wait, wait, what are we alluding to? What happened with the parties? I don't know.
我太，你不被允许去。我有点嫉妒。好吧，我几年前就失去了特权，我觉得我最好远离我们所说的触发环境。我可能应该去做设计。等等，等等，我们在暗示什么？派对上发生了什么？我不知道。
They've got some mutual friends, and they have fun, and they create trips, and they go places. Like recently or in the past? trips of O'Connes, yeah. Yeah, I think recently, yeah. And then I, you know, I stay home and I just, I work on, I work on stuff. I do charity work, you know, and I fix the house, I take care of the kids. That's what we're watching TV now, huh? Yeah.
他们有一些共同的朋友，他们玩得很开心，他们策划旅行，他们去各种地方。是最近还是过去？奥康纳的旅行，是的。是的，我想是最近，是的。然后我，你知道，我待在家里，我只是，我处理，我处理事情。我做慈善工作，你知道，我修理房子，我照顾孩子。这就是我们现在看电视的内容，对吧？是的。
Can you share? Chris, hi, nice to meet you, by the way. Hi, Chris. Thank you for being here. See you guys. Can you share with us one of those vacations or trips? They're hard to recall, aren't they? Yeah, they're quite a blur.
你能分享一下吗？克里斯，嗨，顺便说一句，很高兴见到你。嗨，克里斯。谢谢你来到这里。再见，伙计们。你能和我们分享一下那些假期或旅行吗？很难回忆起来，对吧？是的，它们相当模糊。
The last one was at Palm Springs and there was about, oh, that's nice. 50 or 60 people flying out there and it was quite a big three-day event. Sounds so good. And you were missed, Jason, but we talked about it. I would have, I would have crushed me. You would have been back in the day. Back in the old days. I'd still be there.
上一次是在棕榈泉，大约有，哦，那很好。50或60人飞到那里，那是一个相当大的为期三天的活动。听起来真不错。杰森，你错过了，但我们谈过这件事。我本来会，我本来会崩溃的。你本来会在那儿的。在过去的日子里。我还会待在那儿。
Hey, Will, you know what, Will, it's amazing you and I never partied. I know. We did. We've been through this. We did one night. Jason doesn't Chris. Jason doesn't remember, but before our privileges were suspended. Years ago, Jason and I had a night out. I don't want to get into the details of...
嘿，威尔，你知道吗，威尔，真神奇，你和我从来没一起派对过。我知道。我们有过。我们经历过这个。我们有过一个晚上。杰森不记得了，克里斯。杰森不记得了，但在我们的特权被暂停之前。几年前，杰森和我出去过一个晚上。我不想深入细节……
But we were irresponsible in our 20s. There were moments where... We had fun. I had some fun with David Cross, too, a couple of times, too. Anyway, done that, did that. Three iPhones and cameras and you can kind of... Jason one time he took his belt off. He tried to climb a light pole once.
但我们在20多岁时很不负责任。有那么几个时刻……我们玩得很开心。我和大卫·克罗斯也玩过几次。总之，做过，经历过。三部iPhone和摄像机，你可以……杰森有一次脱掉了他的皮带。他曾经试图爬上一根灯柱。
I was with him and David Cross, and I only stayed late because I was, like, looking out for their safety because they were both acting like ding-dongs. I remember I stole your, I had your belt for like two years. Yeah, why did my belt come off? It would happen just after that. Was I looking to self-sphyxiae?
我和他还有大卫·克罗斯在一起，我留到很晚只是因为，我在照顾他们的安全，因为他们俩都像傻瓜一样行事。我记得我偷了你的，我有你的皮带大概两年了。是的，为什么我的皮带会掉下来？就在那之后发生的。我当时是在寻求自我窒息吗？
Oh, my God. Anyway, Chris, welcome to Smarty. I want to start, like, in the intro, like, learn, I've read so much about you coming up to this, and I knew none of this. First of all, I just want to, in the intro, you named your son after Brad Pitt's character. Is that true?
天哪。总之，克里斯，欢迎来到Smartless。我想从介绍开始，就像，学习，我在来这儿之前读了很多关于你的资料，但我对此一无所知。首先，我只想，在介绍中，你以布拉德·皮特在电影中的角色给你的儿子命名。这是真的吗？
Tristan? It was a... Legend of the Fall. And did you talk about it with your wife? Yeah, no. So we liked the name, and then we were sitting on the couch one day. We had a few different ideas, and that film came on. And the scene where he's on the horse and rolls into the space across the field
特里斯坦？那是……《燃情岁月》。你和你妻子商量过吗？是的，没有。所以我们喜欢这个名字，然后有一天我们坐在沙发上。我们有几个不同的想法，那部电影就播出了。那个场景，他骑在马上，滚进田野对面的空间，
and couldn't look more legendary. And me and my wife, both went, oh, this is the coolest character ever, isn't it? And his name was Tristan. And I was like, what about Tristan? How about that? That could work, and off we went. How about that? That's pretty cool.
看起来再传奇不过了。我和我妻子都说，哦，这是有史以来最酷的角色，不是吗？他的名字叫特里斯坦。我就说，特里斯坦怎么样？那个怎么样？那行得通，然后我们就决定了。那个怎么样？那太酷了。
Now, has your kid grown into that name? Does he look like a Tristan now to you? He does. I mean, he's short of hair now, but he had for the first kind of, he's 11 now, for the first kind of nine, ten years, he didn't cut his hair, so it was long, blonde hair.
现在，你的孩子长得像那个名字了吗？在你看来他现在看起来像个特里斯坦吗？是的。我的意思是，他现在头发剪短了，但他有，他现在11岁了，前九、十年，他没剪过头发，所以是长长的金发。
I mean, you really went with the legends of the fall. I didn't know if it was an influence by outdoing or whether there was some sort of... It wasn't a Halloween costume. No. Did he look like many things? Thor? He absolutely did, yeah.
我的意思是，你真的选择了《燃情岁月》。我不知道这是否受到影响，或者是否有某种……那不是万圣节服装。不。他看起来像很多东西吗？雷神？他绝对像，是的。
And he's incredibly high energy and rides horses and motorbikes and surfs and so he fits the name. And did you ever... Did you ever meet Brad and tell him that? Not that particular story, no. I met Pat once and a big fan, obviously, and kind of had this awkward interaction
而且他精力极其充沛，骑马、骑摩托车、冲浪，所以他很符合这个名字。你有没有……你有没有见过布拉德并告诉他这件事？没有那个特别的故事，没有。我见过帕特一次，显然是他的大粉丝，然后有那种尴尬的互动，
where I went for the handshake. Or he went for the handshake, I went for the hug, that kind of in-between thing. Oh, God, that. It was almost turned into a kiss, and then I was going out of the party. My God, it would slow down too slow for me at that moment. I was standing across the room, my agent was like, he wants to meet you. I'm like, no, he doesn't want to meet me, whatever.
我伸手去握手。或者他伸手去握手，我伸手去拥抱，那种中间状态。哦，天哪，那个。差点变成了一个吻，然后我就要离开派对。天哪，那一刻对我来说太慢了。我站在房间对面，我的经纪人说，他想见你。我说，不，他不想见我，随便吧。
And then eventually an hour later, I was like, oh, Brad, you're here. Oh, just trying to act all. Much on, go on. Hey, look at you. One of those. Where are you today? Are you down under? No, in New York.
然后最终一个小时后，我说，哦，布拉德，你在这儿。哦，只是试图表现得。继续，继续。嘿，看看你。其中之一。你今天在哪儿？你在澳洲吗？不，在纽约。
I'm in a press tour for crime, one of the. one, a filmer promoting. Oh, I can't wait to see that. You know where he is, J.B. Look, you can see where he is. Oh, yeah, yeah, that's, that's right. That's our place. That light switch right there turns on the fireplace.
我正在为《犯罪101》进行新闻巡演，其中一部。一部，正在宣传的电影。哦，我迫不及待想看了。你知道他在哪儿，JB。看，你可以看到他在哪儿。哦，是的，是的，那是，那是对的。那个灯开关就在那儿，打开壁炉。
If you've been looking. That's what that does. Yeah, I never knew where, yeah, it's going to take a little while. It's going to click for a bit. You won't explode. Hey, that Bart Layton. I love that guy. What a great director he is.
如果你一直在找的话。那就是它的作用。是的，我从来不知道在哪儿，是的，这需要一点时间。它会咔哒响一会儿。你不会爆炸的。嘿，那个巴特·莱顿。我喜欢那个家伙。他真是个伟大的导演。
I can't wait to see your film. I just saw it last night. It was fantastic. Oh, you loved it. Yeah. Incredible. Yeah. Add you your seat the whole time.
我迫不及待想看你的电影了。我昨晚刚看了。太棒了。哦，你喜欢它。是的。不可思议。是的。全程让你坐在座位边缘。
No notes? A couple. It's locked? They're not locked yet. Always notes. Okay. If you want to give us some really nuts off air, I can, I won't take them so personally. No, Chris, don't you want, don't you want some, don't you want to do a film next that doesn't
没有意见？有几个。锁定了？还没锁定。总是有意见。好吧。如果你想在节目外给我们一些真正的建议，我可以，我不会那么往心里去的。不，克里斯，你不想，你不想接下来拍一部电影，不需要
take, like, six months to shoot and all these sort of life-threatening stunts you've got to do? And don't you want, like, a nice, calm sort of like a, like the equivalent of a sitcom in a movie? Sure. You know, that you can just relax. Yeah. Yeah, the four, five, six months shoots are tedious. And I know you've all experienced this,
花六个月时间拍摄，还有所有那些你必须做的危及生命的特技吗？你不想，像，一部电影里情景喜剧的等价物吗？当然。你知道，你可以放松一下。是的。是的，四、五、六个月的拍摄很乏味。我知道你们都经历过这个，
but unnecessary too, I feel like at this point. You know, like the technology, cameras and lighting and what you're doing post-production. And everything is still done how we did it. Ten, twenty years ago. Yeah. And you have, you know, 20 big trucks there full of equipment sitting there just in case,
但在这一点上，我觉得也是不必要的。你知道，像技术、摄像机和灯光，以及你在后期制作中所做的事情。一切仍然像我们十、二十年前那样做。是的。而且你有，你知道，20辆装满设备的大卡车坐在那里以防万一，
and especially on the bigger the budget, you know. And you just stand around and do nothing. Then you do a smaller film, and everyone's, it's fast pace, you don't have the luxury to sit around and wonder, and it feels like the preparation's almost done in a far more specific way because there's such a limited time frame.
特别是在预算越大的情况下，你知道。你只是站在周围什么都不做。然后你拍一部小电影，每个人都在，节奏很快，你没有奢侈的时间坐在周围想，而且感觉准备工作几乎是以一种更具体的方式完成的，因为时间框架非常有限。
And I love that style of working. Like I grew up working on a soap opera, and it was the wood shoot 20 scenes a day. And as, you know, the scripts were not great, but you made them work. But just the momentum you get from that and the sort of just by having your feet on the ground continuously day after day,
我喜欢那种工作风格。就像我在肥皂剧里长大，每天要拍20场戏。而且，你知道，剧本并不好，但你让它们发挥作用。但仅仅是那种动力，以及通过日复一日地脚踏实地，
the knowledge you gained from that, I think, is fantastic. Yeah, and learning to be good quick, right? Like, you've got to be good fast on those soap operas, yeah? Yeah, yeah. What was the soap operas? Or you learn to be bad fast, too, which is what most of what I did. Yeah, we just had Margot Robbie
你从中获得的知识，我认为是极好的。是的，学习快速变好，对吧？就像，你在那些肥皂剧里必须快速变好，对吧？是的，是的。是什么肥皂剧？或者你也学会快速变坏，这正是我所做的大部分事情。是的，我们刚请了玛格特·罗比，
and she said she was on a showdown the same one. Yeah, I did neighbors for like an episode and then I did Home and Away, which is the sort of competing one for like three years. And when Margo was on, she talked about when she moved to L.A. that there was like an Australian mafia that helped each other out kind of thing.
她说她也在同一个节目里。是的，我演了《邻居》大概一集，然后我演了《聚散离合》，那是那种竞争对手，演了大概三年。当玛格特在的时候，她谈到当她搬到洛杉矶时，有一个澳大利亚黑手党互相帮助之类的东西。
You know what I mean? Were you part of that? There was like a drive. I was the honest. I always felt there was the Australian Mafia kind of film industry and then the folks that had trained at Nider and I think Mel Gibson and Cape Blanchet and the big acting schools
你知道我的意思吗？你是其中的一部分吗？有一种动力。我一直觉得有澳大利亚黑手党电影产业，然后是在NIDA受过训练的人，我想梅尔·吉布森和凯特·布兰切特以及那些大表演学校，
and then the theatre group and then I was on the soap opera and I always felt a little outside of that cool mafia bubble and I remember kind of turning up to a few premieres and kind of being on the guest list but not really and having all those awkward moments and honestly when I came to L.A.,
然后是剧团，然后我在肥皂剧里，我一直觉得有点在那酷黑手党泡沫之外，我记得参加了几个首映式，有点在嘉宾名单上，但并不是真的，并且有所有那些尴尬的时刻，老实说，当我来到洛杉矶时，
I didn't know that whole crew of Australian people And I started working and eventually met them all and, you know, Joel Edgerton and a few folks that, you know, good friends of mine now. Love that, Joel. I always felt I was, I did this, you know, I did side proper, I did dancing with the stars, so I wasn't seen as being taken seriously.
我不认识那一整群澳大利亚人，我开始工作，最终遇到了他们所有人，你知道，乔尔·埃哲顿和一些人，你知道，现在是我很好的朋友。喜欢那个，乔尔。我一直觉得我是，我做了这个，你知道，我做了肥皂剧，我做了《与星共舞》，所以我没被视为被认真对待。
Wow. Everyone was giving you the Brad Pitt handshake. Yeah. Did you rent a car from the Romanian guy? Margo went to the car from a Romanian dude who didn't require any ID. Oh, God, no. He said away from him. Good, yeah.
哇。每个人都给了你布拉德·皮特的握手。是的。你从那个罗马尼亚人那里租了车吗？玛格特从一个不需要任何身份证的罗马尼亚人那里租了车。哦，天哪，不。他离他远点。好，是的。
Good. No. Well, now I imagine you're fully embraced, and it's all one big party. It is. It is. Because it's, it is such a small industry, you know. And those who have had success in Australia and make the leap overseas and work, there is just such a cool gang of, you know, people in support now.
好。不。好吧，现在我想你已经完全被接纳了，这全是一个大派对。是的。是的。因为这是一个非常小的行业，你知道。那些在澳大利亚取得成功并跨越海外工作的人，现在确实有一群很酷的、互相支持的人。
It's remarkable, again, we said it with Marco, but it's remarkable how many Australians come off those two shows and come and have huge success in this country. in the film business. It's remarkable. It really is. It's the S&L of Australia. Yeah. You know what I mean?
这很了不起，我们再次和玛格特说了，但令人惊讶的是，有多少澳大利亚人从那两个节目中走出来，并在这个国家的电影行业取得了巨大的成功。这很了不起。确实如此。这是澳大利亚的SNL。是的。你知道我的意思吗？
S&L borns so many stars. All right, so you're in New York and you're doing a bunch of press for Crime 101. I would imagine you're going to do a talk show or two, but are you noticing, are you doing like some of the content stuff that is kind of like a part of most of these press tours now? Like, Willie, I know you've got a hot wings out there.
SNL诞生了这么多明星。好吧，所以你在纽约，你正在为《犯罪101》做大量的新闻宣传。我想你会参加一两个脱口秀节目，但你有没有注意到，你是否在做一些现在大多数新闻巡演中那种内容的东西？比如，威尔，我知道你那里有热辣鸡翅。
I still haven't seen, but I'm dying too. I saw a clip some of this really fun. So, like, every, have you been doing some of that stuff? Yeah, I did, I actually did Hot Wings for a previous film, a lot of fun. Yeah. Not on this trip. How far did you get? Did you do all 10?
我还没看过，但我很想看。我看到了一些片段，真的很有趣。所以，像，每一，你有没有做过一些那种东西？是的，我做了，我实际上为之前的电影做过热辣鸡翅，很有趣。是的。这次旅行没做。你走了多远？你做了全部10个吗？
I did, and I was getting really cocky and kind of just more, more, more, more, and this one's not so bad. And Will, you know, by the, like, the 9th or 10th one, it's just a different game. And they just stopped recording because I was like, they had to throw up, and they got me ice cream and milk, and I was, like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And we were all supposed to get out for dinner that night. And I hadn't eaten all day. And by the time I did the show, it was the first thing I put in my stomach was just a bowl of hot sauce.
我做了，而且我变得非常自大，有点只是更多、更多、更多，这个没那么糟糕。威尔，你知道，到第9或第10个的时候，这完全是另一回事了。他们只是停止了录制，因为我当时，他们不得不呕吐，他们给我拿了冰淇淋和牛奶，我当时，是的，是的，是的，是的。我们那天晚上本来都应该出去吃晚饭的。我一整天都没吃东西。当我做节目的时候，我胃里放的第一样东西就是一碗辣酱。
And then I just went back to the hotel room and I sat there for the next 12 hours hugging the toilet bowl. Did you sit down? I was just on the floor. Nothing was operating properly. Everything wanted to come out. Why does it? It's so, I had to take the ice cream,
然后我就回酒店房间，在接下来的12个小时里坐在那儿抱着马桶。你坐下了吗？我只是在地板上。什么都不正常运作了。一切都想出来。为什么它？太，我不得不拿冰淇淋，
and I ended up slathering it on my lips like zinc, like a surfer. Tell me slow. And then was it dripping down your chin? It was, honestly, at one point I was like, I wanted to rip, like it was spurting so bad. And I was just the whole time, I was slightly angry. Yeah, and then you enjoyed a second.
最后我把它像锌一样涂在嘴唇上，像个冲浪者。告诉我慢点。然后它顺着你的下巴滴下来了吗？是的，老实说，有一次我当时想，我想撕裂，因为它喷得太厉害了。我全程都有点生气。是的，然后你享受了一秒钟。
He just kept looking at Lewis Kay. By the way, I did. I called them out. And by the way, the only reason I went all the way through is because they told me, J.B., that you had made it all the way through. Sure, not a problem. Shut up.
他一直看着刘易斯·凯。顺便说一句，我做了。我叫了他们。顺便说一句，我之所以坚持到底，是因为他们告诉我，JB，你已经坚持到底了。当然，没问题。闭嘴。
This mouth can take a lot. Hey, but I only said one bite. enjoyable about having it that hot. Anybody wants to have that shit on their food? I know, but did you eat the whole wing? I just took one bite. No, one bite, one bite. Yeah, that's all it took.
这嘴能吃很多。嘿，但我只说了一口。吃那么辣有什么享受的？有人想在他们的食物上放那种屎吗？我知道，但你吃完整个鸡翅了吗？我只咬了一口。不，一口，一口。是的，只需要一口。
That's a mistake. Well, Chris ate the bones. That's why you threw up. Yeah. But it was just on, I did Graham Norton with John Bishop. Oh, wow. Yeah, oh, nice. Lovely bloke.
那是个错误。好吧，克里斯吃了骨头。这就是你呕吐的原因。是的。但这只是在，我和约翰·毕晓普一起做了格雷厄姆·诺顿秀。哦，哇。是的，哦，不错。可爱的家伙。
Yeah. A fantastic film, by the way. Oh, thanks, man. He's a great dude, isn't he? He's great. He's amazing, and he told the whole story. And, yeah, we're just, what a beautiful. What a beautiful story?
是的。顺便说一句，一部精彩的电影。哦，谢谢，伙计。他是个很棒的家伙，不是吗？他很棒。他很了不起，他讲了整个故事。而且，是的，我们只是，多么美丽。多么美丽的故事？
The kind of thing you can't write, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah, real life kind of shows you the better stories. I love that. What would the sequel be on that, Willie? What would be the sequel? Is this thing still on? What's going on? Is this thing still on?
那种你写不出来的东西，你知道我的意思吗？是的，是的，现实生活向你展示了更好的故事。我喜欢那个。那部电影的续集会是什么，威尔？续集会是什么？这东西还在开着吗？怎么了？这东西还在开着吗？
What's John Bishop? Yeah, what would happen with you? You'd go to the Olympics with Laura, right? By the way, no bad pitches. Keep going. And she'd win the gold. As a coach. She'd win the gold as a coach.
什么是约翰·毕晓普？是的，你会发生什么？你会和劳拉一起去奥运会，对吧？顺便说一句，没有坏的推销。继续。她会赢得金牌。作为教练。她会作为教练赢得金牌。
as a coach, yeah. And then you guys would go on tour doing a stand-up, stand-up tour as a couple. And I'd get canceled. And I'd get canceled on tour. And then it would be, you know, what... Let's write it. Yeah, let's write it.
作为教练，是的。然后你们会去巡演，作为一对夫妇进行单口喜剧巡演。我会因为巡演被取消。然后它会是，你知道，什么……让我们写下来。是的，让我们写下来。
It writes itself. Chris, I haven't seen you since we were singing that song and that car on that crazy commercial we did. Karaoke? No, what was it? It was for a video game. For a video game. Some head-banging...
它自己就写好了。克里斯，自从我们在那个疯狂的广告里唱那首歌和那辆车以来，我就没见过你了。卡拉OK？不，那是什么？那是为了一个电子游戏。为了一个电子游戏。一些甩头……
Sounds like a payday. Yeah. Yeah. And artistic, you know, integral expression, all of that. Yeah, yeah, that too. It was a crazy huge production for a video game commercial, wasn't it?
听起来像个发薪日。是的。是的，还有艺术，你知道，完整的表达，所有这些。是的，是的，那个也是。那是一个电子游戏广告的疯狂巨大制作，不是吗？
It was a mobile game. Yeah, yeah. It was, well, God, what was it called? Chris, do you play the... We had fun, though. We loved it, we loved it so much. We love whatever it was. Did you play those video games
那是一个手机游戏。是的，是的。那是，好吧，天哪，它叫什么？克里斯，你玩那个……我们玩得很开心，虽然。我们喜欢它，我们非常喜欢它。我们喜欢它是什么。你玩那些电子游戏吗
that you need, like, a headset to play? You know, you're shooting people up? No. Really does that. No. Well, you don't still do that, do you? I don't. It's been years, actually, to be honest.
你需要耳机才能玩？你知道，你在射击人？不。真的那样做。不。好吧，你现在还不那样做，是吗？我不。老实说，已经好几年了。
Yeah. I want to know. Sean, you're into Sonic, aren't you? The burgers or? No. Immediately to food. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show.
是的。我想知道。肖恩，你喜欢索尼克，对吧？汉堡还是？不。立刻想到食物。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
So, Chris, I want to know about growing up and talk to me how that started and where the first love came from. Like, what was the first thing? Also, like also an acting family, Sean. It should be pointed out. No, for sure. Well, I was getting there, well.
所以，克里斯，我想知道关于成长，跟我说说那是怎么开始的，第一次爱是从哪里来的。就像，第一件事是什么？还有，也是一个演艺家庭，肖恩。应该指出这一点。不，当然。好吧，我正要说到那儿，威尔。
Well, I'm sorry. Yeah, neither of my parents were actors. My mom has more of an artistic flair. You know, she paints a lot and writes. And was interested in acting, and then she got pregnant with my older brother when she was 19, and then had me and then had my younger brother, and so we kind of ruined her dreams in that sense.
好吧，我很抱歉。是的，我的父母都不是演员。我妈妈更有艺术天赋。你知道，她画画很多，也写作。并且对表演感兴趣，然后她在19岁时怀上了我哥哥，然后有了我，然后有了我弟弟，所以我们在某种意义上毁了她的梦想。
And there's three? Are there any more than the three brothers? No, it's just the three of us, yeah. There's three, yeah. And I grew up in Melbourne and then moved to Northern Territory in the Outback and lived in an Aboriginal community there. And my dad was mustard cattle and buffalo and so on. And it was the complete removal from the suburban Melbourne city life.
有三个？除了三个兄弟还有更多吗？不，只有我们三个，是的。有三个，是的。我在墨尔本长大，然后搬到了内陆的北领地，住在那里一个原住民社区。我爸爸是放牧牛和水牛等等。这与郊区墨尔本的城市生活完全脱节。
We were literally, you mentioned before, but four and a half hours outside of Catherine, southeast Arnhem Land. and just a different world. Like my most vivid memories and some of the most beautiful memories I've heard from us. How old were you when you left there? I was, the first time I was about four to six and then came back to Melbourne for a year
我们确实，你之前提到过，但在凯瑟琳外四个半小时，阿纳姆地东南部。只是一个不同的世界。就像我最生动的记忆，以及我听到的我们最美好的记忆。你离开那里时多大？我，第一次我大约四到六岁，然后回到墨尔本一年，
and then went back up for another year and a half. Wow. So do you know your way around a farm then with cattle and stuff like that? Could you get by? Yeah, I mean, I was young, you know. I was just kind of exploring and doing, you know. Doesn't make you on.
然后又回去了一年半。哇。那你熟悉农场，有牛之类的东西吗？你能应付吗？是的，我的意思是，我还小，你知道。我只是在探索和做，你知道。不让你成为。
No, no, no, I was around it all and was sort of fascinated. I don't think he gets uncomfortable with a lot, J.B., let's be honest. Yeah. He could be surprised. Unlike me, yeah. He's, you know, he's not skateboarding around Hollywood, you know, going on dishes. I know, I'm so soft. Why am I so soft?
不，不，不，我周围都是这些，并且有点着迷。我不认为他会对很多事情感到不舒服，JB，老实说。是的。他可能会感到惊讶。不像我，是的。他，你知道，他不是在好莱坞滑板，你知道，去洗碗。我知道，我太软弱了。为什么我这么软弱？
I'm grown up out back. But what, but did you have like, this is a dumb question, but in the middle of basically nowhere where you grew up, like, what was the impetus for, did you have a TV and you're like, oh, I want to see? that from that person on that TV show? So the first time we lived there, we were in kind of shanty-looking shacks and then a tent at one point. Like it was proper, like, out in the middle of nowhere on different cattle stations. And so no TV during that time.
我在内陆长大。但是，但是你有，这是一个愚蠢的问题，但在你长大的基本上什么都没有的地方，就像，动力是什么，你有电视，你就像，哦，我想看？那个电视节目里的那个人？所以我们第一次住在那里时，我们住在那种棚屋里，然后有一次住在帐篷里。就像它是真正的，就像，在荒郊野外的不同养牛场。所以那段时间没有电视。
The second time we had a TV, and there was a truck that would come and deliver food and supplies to the community every, you know, month or so on. And he dropped us off a couple of VHS tapes. And I remember watching as a really young kid, Terminator 1, a bunch of other random sort of things,
第二次我们有了电视，有一辆卡车会来给社区运送食物和补给，每，你知道，一个月左右。他给我们留下了几盘录像带。我记得作为一个非常小的孩子看《终结者1》，还有其他一堆随机的东西，
which are great for kids at the age of 5 or 6. Yeah, sure. And it wasn't that that inspired me, but that was kind of, I don't know, my earliest memories of what cinema was and that experience. And then I just love watching movies and not so much to be an actor.
这对5或6岁的孩子来说很棒。是的，当然。并不是那个激励了我，但那是我对电影是什么以及那种体验的最早记忆。然后我只是喜欢看电影，并不是为了成为演员。
It was more of like, I want to be Legerless and Lord of the Rings and I want to go and swing a sword and be in that fantasy world. Right. And again, not escaping what I was in my own world, but just the sheer adventure of it. And then by the time I was 18 and finishing high school,
更像是，我想成为《指环王》里的莱戈拉斯，我想去挥舞剑，进入那个幻想世界。对。而且再次，不是逃避我自己的世界，只是那种纯粹的冒险。然后到我18岁高中毕业时，
it just became a real obsession like it does and like it needs to be, I guess. Right. And then I did, yeah, did the soap opera and then off to LA and then... Wait, I want to get back to... So the Whole Foods truck just drove right up to the community and they just opened up the back?
它就变成了一种真正的痴迷，就像它所做的那样，就像它需要的那样，我想。对。然后我做了，是的，做了肥皂剧，然后去洛杉矶，然后……等等，我想回到……所以全食超市的卡车就直接开到了社区，他们就打开了后门？
There was a big shed in this community. There's a lot of separate communities throughout Arnhem Land and they would do deliveries with basic sort of bits and pieces that would go into this, what was the shop, which was literally just a big shed. I did a documentary actually with my dad. that we go back to that community. And there's the same shed there from 30-something years ago.
这个社区有一个大棚子。阿纳姆地有很多独立的社区，他们会用基本的零碎东西进行运送，这些东西会进入这个，也就是商店，实际上只是一个大棚子。我实际上和我爸爸拍了一部纪录片。我们回到那个社区。那里还有30多年前的同一个棚子。
Did it come back to you? Oh, my God. The huge sort of nostalgia. And the detail to which these places prompted, the vivid memories was astounding. Probably surprised you, right? You didn't know it was going to come back? I thought it would have changed dramatically.
它又回到你脑海里了吗？哦，天哪。那种巨大的怀旧感。这些地方激发的细节，生动的记忆是惊人的。可能让你感到惊讶，对吧？你不知道它会回来？我以为它会发生巨大的变化。
And I went, oh, and I remember every little corner of the little streets we were living on. And I remember what games I was playing at what places and where I was hanging out. And there was this big freezer in the back of their shed where they kept all the cold food, which me and my mate, you should just go and sit in and, you know, eat the chocolate bars and so on because it was so hot out there in the middle of the outback. But it was, yeah, fascinating and beautiful place. And that's still, is that still home? Is that still main base for you, Australia?
然后我说，哦，我记得我们住的小街道的每一个小角落。我记得我在什么地方玩什么游戏，我在哪里闲逛。他们的棚子后面有一个大冰柜，他们存放所有的冷冻食品，我和我的伙伴，你应该进去坐着，你知道，吃巧克力棒之类的，因为内陆地区太热了。但它，是的，迷人而美丽的地方。那仍然是，那仍然是你的家吗？澳大利亚仍然是你的主要基地吗？
Australia, yeah, Byron Bay. We live northern New South Wales now and moved back there 11, 12 years ago. It was kind of like my daughter is 13, my boys were 11, so it was right around the time. My boys were born. And it was just, we kind of set up in L.A.
澳大利亚，是的，拜伦湾。我们现在住在新南威尔士州北部，11、12年前搬回那里。就像我女儿13岁，我儿子11岁，所以正好是那个时候。我儿子出生了。我们有点在洛杉矶安顿下来。
And not enjoying it. You know, like nothing was shooting there. We were filming kind of everywhere else. Well, you're traveling anyway, so you might as well, I mean, it's a lot longer, but you might as well live where you want to live. Is that the idea? Yeah, absolutely. You know, you'd come home and paparazzi and all the sort of the trappings of, you know,
而且不喜欢它。你知道，那里什么都没拍。我们几乎在其他任何地方拍摄。好吧，反正你也在旅行，所以你可能，我的意思是，时间长得多，但你可能也想住在你想住的地方。是这个主意吗？是的，绝对。你知道，你会回家，狗仔队和所有那种，你知道，
living in that space and move back to Australia. And that just was, it's been the greatest decision because it's such a, it's like, you know, when you come back from work, you want to go on a holiday, like coming home for me is it feels like a holiday. We have big farm and horses and motorbikes and surf and. That's so cool. Cool. And that's how, I read that's how you guys, you and your brothers grew up too, just like no helmets, writing, like no supervision, just like crazy, right? Yeah, yeah. No, not because my parents didn't care. It was just because we're...
生活在那个空间里的陷阱，搬回澳大利亚。那只是，这是最伟大的决定，因为它太，就像，你知道，当你从工作中回来时，你想去度假，就像对我来说回家感觉就像度假。我们有大农场、马、摩托车和冲浪。那太酷了。酷。而且我读到你们，你和你的兄弟也是那样长大的，就像没有头盔，骑行，就像没有监督，就像疯狂，对吧？是的，是的。不是因为我父母不在乎。只是因为我们……
No, right. I didn't mean that. Jesus, Sean. Jesus, Sean. No, no. We lived about 20 minutes from, like, the main sort of suburban areas in Melbourne up in the hills. and the nearest neighbor was, you know, a kilometer or two away and it was just all bushland and rainforests sort of set up around us. And so we would just spend, you know, outdoors, adventures
不，对。我不是那个意思。天哪，肖恩。天哪，肖恩。不，不。我们住在离墨尔本山里主要郊区大约20分钟的地方。最近的邻居在，你知道，一两公里外，周围全是灌木丛和雨林。所以我们只会花，你知道，户外，冒险
and playing different characters. And I think that's, to be honest, where the sort of intrigue or interest into, you know, transportation into another... Veeam, like, imagination. So then how do you go from that, from... And you have this sort of interest, and what was the first... audition. Like, what was the first thing you go? Like, I'm going to go read for that.
和扮演不同的角色。而且我认为这就是，老实说，那种对，你知道，传送到另一个……想象力。那么你是怎么从那个，从……你有这种兴趣，第一件事是什么……试镜。就像，第一件事是什么你去做？就像，我要去读那个。
I had a, I did a, like a, every Wednesday night I used to drive an hour and a half into, into the city, into Melbourne to do this acting course. It was like a two-hour, you know, session where they'd record everything you did, and you'd have a little VHS tape, and, and you'd go home and watch it, and you go, wow, it doesn't look anything like I thought it would, and so it's kind of shocked at the system and trial by fire, and a pretty good sort of wake up. But you learn quick, you know, as opposed to just doing acting classes and not ever being confronted with what you're actually putting on screen. You learn a lot from watching yourself. I do about what, you know, oh, shit, don't do that again.
我有一个，我做了一个，就像每个周三晚上我开车一个半小时进城，进墨尔本去上这个表演课。就像一个两小时的，你知道，课程，他们会记录你做的一切，你会有一个小的录像带，然后你回家看它，你说，哇，它看起来一点也不像我想象的那样，所以这有点震惊系统和火的洗礼，一个相当好的唤醒。但你学得很快，你知道，而不是只是上表演课而不面对你实际上在屏幕上放的东西。你从看自己中学到很多。我做关于什么，你知道，哦，该死，别再那样做了。
100%. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And all your little sort of tells or habits or things you're repeating, you're like, oh, wow, that's, I thought I was kind of in a complete different space and I'm doing exactly the same thing I did before. Right, right, right. But I got an agent, and then my first audition was, I think, the first job I got was, I think it was called The Sattel Club. It was a Canadian-Australian show about the...
100%。是的，是的，是的。和你所有的小那种暗示或习惯或你重复的事情，你就像，哦，哇，那是，我以为我在一个完全不同的空间，但我做的和我之前做的一模一样。对，对，对。但我找了个经纪人，然后我的第一次试镜是，我想我得到的第一份工作是，我想它叫《马鞍俱乐部》。这是一个关于……的加拿大-澳大利亚节目。
Sean, you used to run the door at the Sattel Club, didn't you? Run the door! I still do. I still do just for some extra money on that. We take those easy, cheap shots. Feel free to jump in any time you think of one. It was a good show, both around horses and, you know, the horse club.
肖恩，你以前在《马鞍俱乐部》看门，对吧？看门！我还在做。我还在做，只是为了赚点外快。我们采取那些容易的、廉价的手段。随时欢迎你想到一个就插话。那是个好节目，都是关于马和，你知道，马术俱乐部。
And I came in as a vet at the age of 18, you know, as a doogie house in of the vet world. That's funny. Sean would let the bears in, too, as well as... Sure. So he was a vet of sorts, I guess, in that way. Veteran, yeah. Wait, which brother got the first job?
我18岁时以兽医的身份进来，你知道，作为兽医世界的杜吉·豪瑟。那很有趣。肖恩也会让熊进来，以及……当然。所以他算是某种兽医，我想，以那种方式。老手，是的。等等，哪个兄弟得到了第一份工作？
My older brother, Luke. He worked on neighbors actually for a while as a steroid selling football. ball player. That's funny. That's quite a roll. And then... In the intro, I read that one job because you said you wanted to quit.
我哥哥，卢克。他实际上在《邻居》里工作了一段时间，作为一个卖类固醇的足球运动员。那很有趣。那是个相当的角色。然后……在介绍中，我读到那一份工作，因为你说你想辞职。
Like Jason was saying, it always happens that way. When you're like, I can't do this anymore. And then something in the universe goes, wait a minute, you have to. And what was that? Was that cabin in the woods? Yeah, it was. It was.
就像杰森说的，事情总是那样发生。当你像，我不能再做这个了。然后宇宙中的某样东西说，等一下，你必须。那是什么？那是《林中小屋》吗？是的，就是它。就是它。
And it's funny. Is it the universe or is it this sort of you just surrender to the process? Yeah. you remove some of the desperation that may be coming out. You kind of hit fuck it. You kind of, and people can tell. Yeah.
而且很有趣。是宇宙还是这种你只是屈服于过程？是的。你消除了可能出现的一些绝望。你有点去他妈的。你有点，人们能看出来。是的。
It's kind of, it's that sexy indifference, guys. Yeah. No, what is that? What is that expression? So here's what it is. It's a bumper sticker. It's amazing. We've all know what that means.
这是一种，那是性感的冷漠，伙计们。是的。不，那是什么？那是什么表达？所以这就是它。它是个保险杠贴纸。太神奇了。我们都知道那意味着什么。
When you're exhausted or you come in and you hung over or what? And all of a sudden it's like you just, your body just doesn't have the strength to light your, you know, you're being up with adrenaline and you're just kind of sick just in a pocket. And you're not thirsty, you're not looking, you're not desperate, you're just like, this is me, this is the way it is, take it or leave it. And there's something about that. People are like, I like that.
当你精疲力竭，或者你进来时宿醉了，或者怎么着？突然间，你的身体好像没有力气去点燃你的，你知道，你被肾上腺素支撑着，你只是有点病恹恹的。你不渴，你不期待，你不绝望，你只是觉得，这就是我，事情就是这样，爱要不要。这其中有些东西。人们会说，我喜欢那个。
Which it comes through the, like, excessive sort of preparation too, you know what I mean? Like, and that was what I learned. Like, I was, then would try and replicate that by, like, not caring, which, of course, I did care. So it was like, well, how can I get to the point where I can let go? And then it was just about over-preparation and where there was no stone unturned.
这也源于那种过度的准备，你明白我的意思吗？就像，这就是我学到的。就像，我当时会试图通过不在乎来复制那种状态，当然，我其实是在乎的。所以我就在想，好吧，我怎样才能达到那种可以放手的地步？然后关键就在于过度准备，做到滴水不漏。
Then you felt like, well, I've done everything I could. Any time I would walk into a room in audition and feel like, oh, you could have learnt these lines a bit better, or you should have done this, and then that kind of voice takes off and does all sorts of shitty things. You were falling into the trap? I used to fall in this trap of trying to pretend like I didn't care.
然后你会觉得，好吧，我已经尽我所能了。任何时候我走进试镜室，如果觉得，哦，这些台词你本可以背得更好，或者你应该做这个，然后那种声音就会冒出来，做各种糟糕的事情。你陷入了陷阱？我过去常陷入这种假装不在乎的陷阱。
So acting twice. an audition. It was like the most idiotic, most exhausting bullshit thing. Like, I'm already sweating, you know, trying to pretend like I'm not going to sweat. Yeah. Wait, so just the sidebar I was going to say
所以演了两次。一次试镜。这简直是最愚蠢、最让人精疲力竭的废话。就像，我已经出汗了，你知道，还要假装我不会出汗。是的。等等，只是个题外话，我想说
the day the cabin in the woods came out was also the same day my movie Three Stooges came out. But I think you guys beat us. Anyway, moving on. This picture! Let me tell me something about this picture. This idiot. These three, the brother.
《林中小屋》上映的那天，也是我的电影《三个臭皮匠》上映的日子。但我认为你们打败了我们。总之，继续吧。这张照片！让我告诉你关于这张照片的一些事。这个白痴。这三个，兄弟。
It's so stupid. They can't do it. Was it the same guy? Sean, I actually watched 10 minutes of that, like not four days ago. Thank you. What, the three stooges? Yeah, yeah. On the big screen?
太蠢了。他们做不到。是同一个人吗？肖恩，我其实在四天前看了那部电影的10分钟。谢谢。什么，三个臭皮匠？是的，是的。在大银幕上？
You gave it a full 10 minutes? A full 10 here on the TV. And then we lost power or something like that. And so I couldn't see anymore. It literally crashed the power at your house. Jason, you mentioned before you know Bart Leighton or you just know. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm a huge fan of his film American Animals.
你完整看了10分钟？在电视上完整看了10分钟。然后我们停电了之类的。所以我没法再看了。它真的让你家断电了。杰森，你之前提到你认识巴特·莱顿，还是你只是认识。是的，是的，是的。我是他电影《美国动物》的超级粉丝。
Yeah. And I just started pursuing him like some crazy fan after that. And he sat down and had lunch with me and humored me for a bit. But yeah, I cannot wait to see this. He's incredible. This was, I think, the best experience I've ever had in the set. And I've had some amazing times. And it kind of reminded me, to be honest, of like, Furiosa with George Miller felt like this
是的。在那之后，我就像个疯狂的粉丝一样开始追求他。他坐下来和我一起吃午饭，还陪我聊了一会儿。但是，是的，我迫不及待想看这部电影。他太不可思议了。我认为这是我在片场经历过的最好的体验。我经历过一些很棒的时光。说实话，这让我想起了乔治·米勒的《芙莉欧莎》，感觉就像这样
and Rush many years ago. And it's a thing where there's just this beautiful, he is just such a craftsman, such a master, attention to detail is beyond anyone I've ever seen. Some of those shots are incredible. The cinematography is stunning, and he wrote the script, so there's this deeper sort of understanding of every element to it. But then it's just this kind, collaborative,
还有多年前的《极速风流》。这是一种美妙的感觉，他真是一位工匠，一位大师，对细节的关注超过了我见过的任何人。其中一些镜头令人难以置信。摄影效果令人惊叹，而且剧本也是他写的，所以他对每一个元素都有更深层次的理解。但同时他又是一个善良、乐于合作、
humble human being, which you don't get the two come together. I was just going to say, that kind, yeah, kind leadership, right? Ron Howard on Rush, Bart on this. It just, it ends up
谦逊的人，你很难见到这两者结合在一起。我正想说，那种善良，是的，善良的领导力，对吧？罗恩·霍华德在《极速风流》中，巴特在这部电影中。这最终
yielding that great input from this entire team if somebody at the top is not a monster. You should look at that. Yeah, I'm reading and reading. You should take note. Because I've heard a lot of stories
如果高层不是个怪物，就能从整个团队中获得巨大的投入。你应该看看那个。是的，我在读，在读。你应该记下来。因为我听过很多关于
from your sets, from a lot of, I get a lot of anonymous emails. A lot of it. It's true. A lot of it's true. I'm working on it. Yeah, real groucher me.
你片场的故事，很多，我收到很多匿名邮件。很多。这是真的。很多都是真的。我正在努力改进。是的，我真是个爱发牢骚的人。
Groucherton is your nickname. J.K., everybody loves J.K. Wait, so a couple of things I didn't know. Okay. Are we back off the sidebar or we're into mainstream question? I don't know if we have enough time for the segment, things you don't know. No, but look, you got, I love, oh, the places you'll go. Oh, yeah.
“牢骚大王”是你的绰号。开玩笑的，每个人都爱J.K.。等等，有几件事我不知道。好吧。我们是回到题外话还是进入主流问题？我不知道我们是否有足够的时间进行“你不知道的事”这个环节。不，但是看，你得到了，我喜欢，《哦，你要去的地方》。哦，是的。
So you get, right, so when I, first of the, you got. First of all, talk about your tattoos. Then I'll get into that. So you've got tattoos, which I didn't know you've had this many tattoos. So tell us the tattoos you have. Are there a bunch of random kind of... Start with the back tat. Starts the backtip, the Holly Dibeson and the hawk.
所以你得到了，对吧，当我，首先，你得到了。首先，谈谈你的纹身。然后我会进入那个话题。所以你有纹身，我不知道你有这么多纹身。告诉我们你有什么纹身。是一堆随机的……从背部的纹身开始。从背部开始，Holly Dibeson和鹰。
No, no, no, no, the one on the tailbone. Low back. Low, lower. Oh, the barbed wire. The one that says, just breathe. Open for business. Oh, my God. That's hilarious.
不，不，不，不，尾骨上的那个。后腰。低一点，再低一点。哦，铁丝网那个。写着“只管呼吸”的那个。营业中。哦，天哪。太搞笑了。
My tattoos, so I have a Dr. Su's tattoo, my daughter was, I used to read that book to her a lot. And my mum read it to me, oh, the places we go, you'll go. And she just would draw that little character and loved it. And so I got that tattoo. Oh, I love that. Isn't that great? And then a few years later, I was like, I'm kind of sick of it. So I started getting it taken off, and I did like one laser session.
我的纹身，我有一个苏斯博士的纹身，我女儿，我过去常给她读那本书。我妈妈也读给我听，《哦，你要去的地方》。她只是会画那个小角色，非常喜欢。所以我纹了那个纹身。哦，我喜欢那个。那不是很棒吗？几年后，我觉得，我有点厌倦它了。所以我开始把它洗掉，我做了一次激光疗程。
And then she came home one day, she goes, it's rubbing off. What happened to it? It's rubbing off? And I was like, oh, did you still? I thought, I don't know, I thought you were sick of it. She goes, no, I love it, I love it. So it's now kind of half-fated, you know, but it's still there. I love that.
然后有一天她回家，她说，它在褪色。怎么了？它在褪色？我说，哦，你还？我以为，我不知道，我以为你厌倦它了。她说，不，我爱它，我爱它。所以现在它有点半褪色了，你知道，但它还在那里。我喜欢那个。
Another, it's a bunch of my arm, actually, the little drawings that she did that I was sitting with her tattoo artist one night, and it was like 10 o'clock, and he's designing all these different things and all this sort of sacred geometry and trippy-looking stuff. And my daughter walked out and goes, Dad, I can't sleep. You're making too much noise. I'm like, sorry, sorry. And she sits down and starts squiggling. and drew the three little images here,
另一个，我手臂上有一堆，其实是她画的小画，有一天晚上我和她的纹身师坐在一起，当时是10点钟，他正在设计各种不同的东西，还有所有那些神圣几何和看起来很迷幻的东西。我女儿走出来说，爸爸，我睡不着。你太吵了。我说，抱歉，抱歉。她坐下来开始涂鸦，画了这三个小图像，
which one of them is, and the guy next to us goes, that's the wheel of Dharma, it's eight steps to enlightenment. So it's this, she's joined that. Oh, really? And then the five-pointed star, and, you know, so he looked at me and goes, I think they're way cool than anything we're designing, and so took a photo of that, and that's that.
其中一个是，旁边那个人说，那是达摩轮，是通往启蒙的八个步骤。所以是这个，她画的。哦，真的吗？还有五角星，你知道，所以他看着我说，我觉得它们比我们设计的任何东西都酷得多，所以拍了张照片，就是那样。
And then a bunch of other sort of scrimals. And your Avengers friends, which is cool. I made disparaging remarks about people with tattoos on a podcast in the UK. You know that guy, Roma? She's hilarious. Do you know that dude over in London? Anyway, I made a sweeping generalization kind of as a bit, and I got a bunch of hate from it.
还有一堆其他乱七八糟的。还有你的复仇者联盟朋友们，这很酷。我在英国的一个播客上对有纹身的人发表了贬损言论。你知道那个家伙，罗马吗？她太搞笑了。你知道伦敦那个家伙吗？总之，我做了一个概括性的陈述，结果招来了一堆仇恨。
What was it? I was like, I said there's a direct correspondence between the more tattoos you have. By the way, I don't even believe this. The more tattoos you have, the more tattoos you have, the more boring you are. As all I said, it was boring. People freaked out, and I'm like, I'm just fucking around. It's like, I don't have a scientific opinion on this. I'm just fucking around.
是什么？我说，纹身越多，相关性就越直接。顺便说一句，我甚至不相信这一点。纹身越多，你就越无聊。我只说了这个，就是无聊。人们吓坏了，我说，我只是在胡说八道。这就像，我对此没有科学的看法。我只是在胡说八道。
Sounds like someone who would like a few tattoos. Would you like a couple? I would like a couple, actually. I thought you were. I don't have one. All I have are just my kids here and the inside of my arm. That's it. But I feel like I want like a thousand more.
听起来像是一个会喜欢几个纹身的人。你想要几个吗？其实我想要几个。我以为你是。我一个都没有。我只有我孩子们的名字在这里和手臂内侧。就这样。但我感觉我想要再纹一千个。
I feel like the dam is broken. I have a million friends who are covered in tattoos. that would mean that I hate all my friends. The problem is I get sick of them, and so I'm not into them for a few weeks. That's what I'm worried about. I want to just get them all removed. But you're not sick of the ones from your kids, though.
我觉得大坝决堤了。我有一百万个朋友身上全是纹身。那意味着我讨厌我所有的朋友。问题是我会厌倦它们，所以几周后我就没兴趣了。这就是我担心的。我只想把它们全部洗掉。但你不会厌倦你孩子们的那些，对吧。
The kids' ones that have a bit of something to it, but I've got some other ones that are like a weird sort of psychodromatry one, which looks like the Illuminati kind of vibe to it. I love all those little tiny drawing ones, you know? I think like what you were showing on your arm, like just like little doodles. Yeah, that's what I... I love that.
孩子们的那些有点意义，但我还有一些其他的，比如一种奇怪的心理几何纹身，看起来有点光明会的氛围。我喜欢所有那些小小的涂鸦，你知道吗？我想就像你在手臂上展示的那样，就像小涂鸦。是的，那就是我……我喜欢那个。
I want some of those. I love, you know, but then you get a lot. Do you have any of the ones I see people like on their arm? It's like, stay alert. And I'm like, do you have to look at it to remind yourself? And if you're looking at it, you're not alert. Just breathe. Just breathe.
我想要一些那样的。我喜欢，你知道，但你会纹很多。你有我看到人们手臂上的那种吗？就像，“保持警惕”。我就想，你必须看着它来提醒自己吗？如果你在看它，你就没有保持警惕。只管呼吸。只管呼吸。
Oh, right, fuck, fuck. Any quotes or any. I wanted JBI. I always threatened that if the Leafs win the Stanley Cup, I'm going to get my whole back of Wendell Clark, who's been retired for years, but my hockey idol, holding the Stanley Cup on my back.
哦，对了，该死，该死。任何引语或任何。我想要JBI。我总是威胁说，如果枫叶队赢得斯坦利杯，我就要在整个背部纹上温德尔·克拉克，他已经退役多年了，但他是我的冰球偶像，拿着斯坦利杯在我的背上。
I think I'm safe. now for a while. Oh, yeah. We're struggling along with you here in Los Angeles. Sean, you don't have any, right? You don't have any time. No, I've always wanted one. I was wanting like a...
我想我暂时安全了。哦，是的。我们在洛杉矶和你一起挣扎。肖恩，你没有，对吧？你没有任何纹身。不，我一直想要一个。我想要一个……
Let's do one. Let's design, I'll design one for you and then you design one for me. Sean, if you had to put... If you had to get a tattoo of a snack food on your body, what would it be? Oh. You have to go.
我们做一个吧。我为你设计一个，然后你为我设计一个。肖恩，如果你必须……如果你必须在身上纹一个零食，那会是什么？哦。你必须纹。
Guns to your head. One snack food on the body. Yeah. It would have to probably... And it can't be hot dog. Can it be a twinkie? What about a Twinkiekeke? No, it would probably be a Snickers bar.
枪指着你的头。身上纹一个零食。是的。那可能必须……而且不能是热狗。可以是Twinkie吗？Twinkiekeke怎么样？不，那可能是一个士力架。
A Snickers bar. Yeah. Where would you put that? What about right on my neck? Right on your tummy, right across your tummy. That's right there's up. Lower back. Lower back.
一个士力架。是的。你会把它纹在哪里？纹在我的脖子上怎么样？纹在你的肚子上，横跨你的肚子。就在那儿。后腰。后腰。
Because that's what people will snicker. Yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So, Chris, in Crime 101, I mean, we always talk about this on this podcast, but like when people from Australia or the UK have to do these American accents and they're so good and they're so believable
因为那是人们会偷笑的地方。是的。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目。所以，克里斯，在《犯罪101》中，我的意思是，我们在这个播客上总是谈论这个，但是当来自澳大利亚或英国的人必须做这些美国口音时，他们做得非常好，非常可信，
and then you speak in your regular Australia it's just like I don't know what happens it's like how do you do that I could never do an Australian accent that's the hardest one right now no I couldn't do it guns to your hat I can say one word chest is chist that's all I know that sounds more Kiwi Chist
然后你用你平常的澳大利亚口音说话，就像，我不知道发生了什么，就像你怎么做到的？我永远做不到澳大利亚口音，那是现在最难的一种，对吧？不，我做不到。枪指着你的头。我可以说一个词，chest是chist，我只知道这个，听起来更像新西兰口音，Chist。
that sounds like Kiwi sounds like more New Zealand Chis Oh it does We'd say chest. Oh, you would say chest? Say aluminium, Sean. Aluminium. Aluminium.
听起来像新西兰口音，听起来更像新西兰的Chis。哦，确实。我们会说chest。哦，你会说chest？说aluminium，肖恩。Aluminium。Aluminium。
I can do a British one. I can't do it. Oh, let's hear that guy. Let's hear that guy. I mean, I'll visit from that guy. It's, I think, I mean, most about television and film growing up is American, so there's a bit of, you know, we haven't ear for it, I guess. But I've also screwed it up many times as well. Wow.
我可以做一个英国口音的。我做不到。哦，让我们听听那个家伙。让我们听听那个家伙。我的意思是，我会从那个家伙那里访问。我认为，我的意思是，成长过程中关于电视和电影的大部分都是美国的，所以我们对它有一种耳濡目染，我想。但我也有很多次搞砸了。哇。
How often will you go back in? Will you ask, like, you'll see an early cut of something and you'll ask the director, hey, could I go in and redo that line or that line? More now. I didn't even know I had the option in the past. And I see some review talking about not so favorably. And then the worst was a Scottish accent I did for something. And someone said it's the worst Glasgow accent we've heard since the fat bastard in Austin Powers.
你多久会回去重录？你会要求，比如，你看到某样东西的早期剪辑，你会问导演，嘿，我可以进去重做那句台词或那句台词吗？现在更多了。过去我甚至不知道我有这个选择。我看到一些评论谈论得不太好。然后最糟糕的是我为某部电影做的苏格兰口音。有人说这是我们听过的最糟糕的格拉斯哥口音，仅次于《王牌大贱谍》里的“胖混蛋”。
Which is one of the greatest all-time. I was like, you've got a great job. Yeah. I love these guys on the sidelines throwing bombs. They can do it. I know. I think you're brilliant at it. And what about, and then you met,
那是史上最伟大的角色之一。我说，你有一份很棒的工作。是的。我喜欢这些在场边扔炸弹的家伙。他们能做到。我知道。我觉得你在这方面很出色。还有，然后你遇到了，
didn't you meet Elsa your wife through a dialect coach? We did, yeah, yeah, yep, yep. It was a... Like, what was she going for? The dialect coach or Elsa? Yeah, I mean, but I meant like, why were you there at the same time? Oh, no, we were about trining separately with her, and she said, oh, I think you'd like someone else I'm working with.
你不是通过方言教练认识你妻子艾尔莎的吗？我们是，是的，是的，是的，是的。那是一个……就像，她是为了什么？方言教练还是艾尔莎？是的，我的意思是，但我指的是为什么你们同时在那里？哦，不，我们是分别和她训练，她说，哦，我想你会喜欢我正在合作的另一个人。
And I said, oh, what, and I even looked her up and thought, oh, gee, looks lovely, sure, give me a fun of her. Yeah. Really? That was that simple. And then we went up for dinner and then I went and shot a movie and then came back at dinner
我说，哦，什么，我甚至查了她，心想，哦，天哪，看起来很可爱，当然，给我她的电话。是的。真的吗？就那么简单。然后我们出去吃了顿晚餐，然后我去拍了一部电影，然后回来吃了顿晚餐，
and then went off and shot another movie. So it was like we weren't together but we'd sort of been in contact for kind of eight months and then got together and very quickly had kids in marriage and all that fun stuff. But that's nice though,
然后又去拍了另一部电影。所以我们并没有在一起，但我们保持联系了大约八个月，然后在一起了，很快就有了孩子、结婚，所有那些有趣的事情。但这很好，
that's kind of a nice slow burn though. Like you kind of like ease into it a little bit, a couple of dinners are in there and... Yeah, a bit of distance, kind of long distance. Was that a novel idea to you, Will? Just a couple of dates before you start with... Hey, man. Hey, so what else?
那是一种很好的慢热。就像你有点慢慢进入状态，中间有几次晚餐，而且……是的，有点距离，算是异地恋。这对你来说是个新奇的想法吗，威尔？在开始之前先约会几次……嘿，伙计。嘿，还有什么？
So you took her out to date? dinner a couple of times, is you? So Chris, your kids are now at the age where they can see how badass dad is and they can appreciate kind of like what a set is like and that that might be a fun sort of atypical work environment. Any of them getting kind of the bug to do what you do? Any interest there? Yeah, they do.
所以你带她出去约会？吃了几次晚餐，是吗？所以克里斯，你的孩子们现在到了可以看到爸爸有多厉害的年纪，他们可以欣赏片场是什么样的，那可能是一个有趣且非典型的工作环境。他们中有人有兴趣做你做的事吗？有兴趣吗？是的，他们有。
My daughter was in Love and Thunder, the last Thor film. Yeah. And she played Christian Bale's daughter. And then she's... Did she dig it? Yeah, but she was like... I asked her to, you know, I said, look, I can... Do you want to do this role?
我女儿参演了《雷神4：爱与雷霆》，最后一部雷神电影。是的。她扮演了克里斯蒂安·贝尔的女儿。然后她是……她喜欢吗？是的，但她就像……我让她，你知道，我说，看，我可以……你想演这个角色吗？
And she goes, oh, yeah, cool, what do I have to do? And I said, I'll just read these lines. She's, no, I don't want to read the lines. And I was like, well, I'm going to record something to send to Kevin Faggie. She's like, no, I'm not doing it. And I was like, okay, well, you can't do it. She goes, no, but I want to do it. I'm like, yeah, but you got it.
她说，哦，是的，酷，我得做什么？我说，只要读这些台词。她说，不，我不想读台词。我说，好吧，我要录点东西发给凯文·费奇。她说，不，我不做。我说，好吧，那你不能演。她说，不，但我想要演。我说，是的，但你得……
This is like an auditioning. She won't read. So she finds it. finally did it. They were like, great, loved it. And then she did Avengers, and this is three, four years later. And by this point, she's so much more jaded about it. She kind of is like, it doesn't, hates the whole scene and everything. But, you know, it tells me she enjoys acting. We do one take, wide take, mostly sort of in my direction. And she gets up and goes, okay, are we done? I said, no, you're serious? And she goes, how much longer? And I'm like,
这就像试镜。她不肯读。所以她终于做了。他们说，太棒了，很喜欢。然后她演了《复仇者联盟》，这是三四年后。到这个时候，她对这件事已经厌倦多了。她有点像，不喜欢整个场景和一切。但是，你知道，这告诉我她喜欢表演。我们拍了一个镜头，广角镜头，大部分是朝着我的方向。她站起来说，好了，我们完了吗？我说，不，你是认真的吗？她说，还要多久？我说，
We're here all week, and you've done, like, one wide shot. And every single time we'd go back to the tent or the trailer, and they'd call us in, she'd like, oh, God. And I was like, India, you begged me to do this, you wanted to do it. And then her brothers are like, we'll do it, we'll do it, we'll do it. You're such a sook, India. And so they probably have more of, my boys probably have more of a, like, I don't know, they like the kind of, they're a bit more of a showman kind of, you know,
我们整周都在这儿，你只拍了一个广角镜头。每次我们回到帐篷或拖车，他们叫我们进去时，她就说，哦，天哪。我说，英迪亚，你求我让你做这个，你想做它。然后她的兄弟们说，我们会做，我们会做，我们会做。你真是个爱哭鬼，英迪亚。所以他们可能更有，我的男孩们可能更有，我不知道，他们喜欢那种，他们更像是个表演者，你知道，
they like that space. How were the Russo's honor? Did the Ruses take care of her, or was Joe just hammering her with notes? Yes, heaps of a notes. Backstory and incessant on sort of the study and the preps you've done. No, not long. They're fantastic. And Chris, do your kids, I read that they critique your movies?
他们喜欢那个空间。罗素兄弟怎么样？罗素兄弟照顾她了吗，还是乔只是用笔记在敲打她？是的，大量的笔记。背景故事和对你所做的研究和准备的坚持。不，不长。他们太棒了。还有克里斯，你的孩子们，我读到他们会批评你的电影？
Do they actually write them or do they just tell you? No, they'll just blightingly tell me. Yeah, they're tough. But that whole generation, they're like, yeah, visual effects weren't as good and that one, dad. I don't ever remember commenting on it. any of that as a kid.
他们真的会写评论吗，还是只是告诉你？不，他们只是直言不讳地告诉我。是的，他们很严厉。但整整一代人，他们就像，是的，视觉效果没那么好，那一部，爸爸。我不记得我小时候评论过任何这些。
Yeah, my kids never like watching anything that's like five years old. That's sick and stuff. My kids came, my kids came and saw our,
是的，我的孩子们从不喜欢看任何五年前的东西。那太恶心了之类的。我的孩子们来了，我的孩子们来看我们的，
are my brother that is this thing on and Abel, my 15-year-old goes, a lot better than that one the movie you did with the talking dogs. I go,
我兄弟那个东西，还有亚伯，我15岁的孩子说，比你拍的那部有会说话的狗的电影好多了。我说，
hey dude. Yeah. Did your braces get paid for? Yeah. What are you in the house you're living in? Yeah.
嘿，伙计。是的。你的牙套钱付了吗？是的。你住的房子呢？是的。
Pretty comfy? Exactly. Pretty comfy right now? Do your kids, do your kids give it up, Chris, well, like, if you do something great, well, they go, you know, that was awesome. No, no, they're really supportive. They're, um, they remember the first time when they were sort of realizing what it was that I did.
挺舒服的？正是。现在挺舒服的？你的孩子们会夸你吗，克里斯，好吧，就像，如果你做了一些伟大的事情，他们会说，你知道，那太棒了。不，不，他们非常支持。他们，嗯，他们记得第一次当他们意识到我做的是什么的时候。
And the first time my son, I took him to the cinema to watch, to see Thor. And he was just running up and down the aisle. And I was like, just, just got to sit down, shoot down, and he's jumping up and down the chairs. And I was just like, you know, just trying to sit him down and holding him, behind him, on band and then i was like fuck this is my movie i'm fucking on the screen you know i'm not worried about someone's going to yell at us but i thought and then the end he was like
第一次我儿子，我带他去电影院看《雷神》。他只是在过道里跑来跑去。我说，坐下，坐下，他在椅子上跳上跳下。我只是，你知道，试图让他坐下，抱着他，在他身后，在……然后我说，该死，这是我的电影，我他妈的在屏幕上，你知道，我不担心有人会冲我们大喊大叫，但我以为，最后他就像
having so much fun he's sweating he's sweating and he's like right let's go and then so he left halfway through and he ran up and down the hallway he's like that his temperate's big but but he became obsessed with it and had a little hammer that he run around with and smash things and oh really that's true i mean that's cool
玩得很开心，他出汗了，他出汗了，他说，好了，我们走吧，然后他中途离开了，他在走廊里跑来跑去，他就像，他的脾气很大，但但他变得痴迷于它，有一个小锤子，他跑来跑去砸东西，哦，真的吗？那是真的，我的意思是那很酷。
i mean that's pretty cool i get it my my my 15 old wishes you were his dad too. It's unbelievable. It's a long line of kids. But it's changing, like the 11, 13 year old time when there's a whole new vernacular and all this sort of new language they seem
我的意思是那很酷，我明白了，我15岁的孩子也希望你是他的爸爸。这太不可思议了。有一长串的孩子。但这在改变，就像11、13岁的时候，有一种全新的词汇和所有这些他们似乎使用的那种新语言，
to roll with and everything's got like a sarcastic sort of twist to it now because all the YouTube shit and so on. And I'll say something and they've got like, ugh, cringe. I'm like, no, no, no, no. I'm fucking cool, right? I'm not, I'm not. I'm not. I'm going to cool with dads, right? And it's like,
而且一切现在都有了一种讽刺的意味，因为所有的YouTube垃圾等等。我会说些什么，他们就会说，呃，尴尬。我说，不，不，不，不。我他妈的很酷，对吧？我不，我不。我不。我要和爸爸们一起酷，对吧？就像，
All right, right. It's all fighting in the distance. I love that. You know, the Avengers Doomsday, I was at Anthony Rousseau's house, and we saw the trailer. We were the first people to see the trailer. Yeah. It was incredible.
好吧，好吧。远处都在打架。我喜欢那个。你知道，《复仇者联盟：末日》，我在安东尼·罗素家，我们看了预告片。我们是第一批看到预告片的人。是的。太不可思议了。
That's cool. This will be the, I don't know if you know this. This will be the 10th time you've played Thor, which is really cool. It's wild, isn't it? I know. Wow. It's wild. I mean, that's really, really, really cool.
那很酷。这将是，我不知道你是否知道这一点。这将是你第10次扮演雷神，这真的很酷。太疯狂了，不是吗？我知道。哇。太疯狂了。我的意思是，这真的，真的，真的非常酷。
Yeah. Oh, really? There's more? Yeah. Oh, that's great. Yeah. But it's just been the, it's been so much fun. And what I've really enjoyed is unlike, I think, a lot of what the other characters
是的。哦，真的吗？还有更多？是的。哦，那太棒了。是的。但这一直，一直很有趣。我真正喜欢的是，不像，我认为，很多其他角色
that the scripts were given, they have had to be pretty consistent. Whereas working with Tyker on his films versus Kenneth Branagh with those films. And then from, you know, with the Rousseau's, all quite a different sort of tonal opinion, but also, let me kind of try different things because I was getting, same with my tattoos, I'd be getting really bored of the same thing and having a real need to kind of just throw it in different directions. And I was talking to Kevin about it and he said,
给出的剧本，他们必须保持相当的一致性。而与塔伊加合作他的电影，或者与肯尼思·布拉纳合作那些电影。然后从，你知道，与罗素兄弟合作，所有这些在基调上都有很大的不同，但也让我尝试不同的东西，因为我变得，就像我的纹身一样，我会对同样的事情感到非常厌倦，并且有一种真正的需求去把它推向不同的方向。我和凯文谈过这件事，他说，
oh, it's cool because the audience now expect dramatic turns with the character and whatever we do next, that we've got some ideas to do something pretty unique again and hopefully be... Yeah, I was going to say, you must have ideas, you guys all must have ideas about where your characters might go. Because now you guys, I guess for a long time now, you guys have been going, there aren't comic books to write these scripts off of.
哦，这很酷，因为观众现在期待角色的戏剧性转变，无论我们接下来做什么，我们都有一些想法去做一些非常独特的事情，希望能够……是的，我正想说，你一定有想法，你们一定都有关于角色走向的想法。因为现在你们，我想很长一段时间以来，你们一直在进行，没有漫画书可以参考来写这些剧本。
You guys have gone past those. And so do you guys, is there an... But there's also an obligation, though, J.B., within... Isn't there, like, not an obligation, but, like, because the fans are so... They know these characters so well, so you've got to handle it kind of with care. Like, you take chances.
你们已经超越了那些。所以你们，有没有……但也有义务，J.B.，在……难道没有，不是义务，而是，因为粉丝们太……他们非常了解这些角色，所以你必须小心处理。就像，你冒险。
Yeah. Yeah. But you've also got to, like, make sure that... they don't get pissed off. No, for sure, because you, I mean, you still can pull from, there's so many different stories within the comic books, and you pull from ideas and certain, you know, directions. And even within the different comic book artists, writers,
是的。是的。但你也必须，确保……他们不会生气。不，当然，因为你，我的意思是，你仍然可以借鉴，漫画书里有这么多不同的故事，你借鉴想法和某些，你知道，方向。即使在不同的漫画书艺术家、作家中，
they had sort of slightly different takes as well, so there's variations. But you do have to be careful, because when we made Ragnarok, it was quite a twist, you know, and with Tiker's time. Such a great movie. And it was so fun. And there was a huge kind of like appreciation for the shift. And then Love and Thunder was kind of like a Monty Python sketch.
他们也有稍微不同的看法，所以有变化。但你确实必须小心，因为当我们制作《诸神黄昏》时，那是一个很大的转折，你知道，在塔伊加的时间里。这么棒的电影。而且非常有趣。人们对这种转变有巨大的赞赏。然后《爱与雷霆》有点像蒙提·派森的短剧。
And we sort of took the piss probably a little much. And then there was some of that backlash, you know, that there was the real kind of, why is you a goofball and why is it this? And, you know, violently offended. And we were like, oh, we're just, you know, having fun or trying to try something different. But it is cool that there's that partnership there. though with the audience as well as the filmmaker that doesn't really exist
我们可能有点开过头了。然后出现了一些反弹，你知道，那种真正的，为什么你是傻瓜，为什么是这样？而且，你知道，被严重冒犯了。我们就像，哦，我们只是，你知道，玩得开心或者试图尝试不同的东西。但这种伙伴关系确实很酷，
in other I mean maybe Star Wars there's some of that as well but um it's that part is really cool Star Wars sorry I mean if you can stick around for a couple hours Chris okay
尽管与观众以及电影制作人之间，这在其他地方并不真正存在，我的意思是也许《星球大战》也有一些，但是……那部分真的很酷。《星球大战》，抱歉，我的意思是如果你能留几个小时，克里斯，好吧，
but Star Wars wait what about like in the intro I didn't know this is total left turn but when you were growing up you repaired breast milk pumps what? Yeah I worked for Fisher and Parko
但是《星球大战》，等等，开场白里是怎么回事？我不知道，这完全是左转，但当你成长过程中，你修理母乳泵，什么？是的，我为Fisher and Paykel工作，
this home what do you call it, white goods kind of, yeah, fridges and so on. They also make dishwashers. Dishwashers. And they make breast bumps.
这个家，你叫它什么，白色家电之类的，是的，冰箱等等。他们也制造洗碗机。洗碗机。他们还制造母乳泵。
They make the, I didn't know that. And they would rent them to different pharmacies and chemists and they would come back to us and I'd have to repair them when the little belt, the motor belt would break.
他们制造，我不知道。他们会把它们租给不同的药店和化学家，它们会回到我们这里，当小皮带，电机皮带断裂时，我必须修理它们。
It would also have to clean all the dried milk that was on them. So I'd have a toothed brush and spray and wipe. And that was my first, my first job. How about that? A lot of time to think about what else I would prefer to be doing.
我还必须清理上面所有干涸的牛奶。所以我有一个牙刷和喷雾，擦拭。那是我的第一份工作。那怎么样？有很多时间去思考我更愿意做什么。
Yeah, for sure. And you're a big surfer, and you do snowboarding, and it's like, by the way, is there snow there in Australia right now? Opposite. It's summer now. But I was just in Korshevall, France, last week with my family. Did you do some skiing? Yeah, a lot of skiing, snowboarding,
是的，当然。你是个冲浪高手，你还玩单板滑雪，顺便问一下，澳大利亚现在有雪吗？相反。现在是夏天。但我上周和家人在法国库尔舍瓦勒。你滑雪了吗？是的，滑了很多雪，单板滑雪，
and kids are all doing backflips. You must have played a lot of sports growing up. Yeah, I did the 110 hurdles. That was my event. Really? It wasn't quite quick enough for the 100, but I was tall enough and agile enough for the hurdles, so it was a good combination.
孩子们都在做后空翻。你成长过程中一定参加了很多运动。是的，我参加了110米栏。那是我的项目。真的吗？我跑100米不够快，但我足够高，足够敏捷，适合跨栏，所以这是一个很好的组合。
What about footy? Do you play any footy? AFL football, yep. A NFL? Played for eight or nine years, and then when I was 17, I dislocated my shoulder and tore all the ligaments. And I'd been surfing a lot at the same time,
橄榄球呢？你玩橄榄球吗？AFL橄榄球，是的。NFL？玩了八九年，然后我17岁时肩膀脱臼，韧带撕裂。我当时同时冲浪很多，
and so I'd eight weeks of sitting on the couch doing nothing, and I was like, I don't want to risk not surfing anymore. And then sort of gave that up. Must be a lot of dislocated shoulders in the NFL football. Every injury I have now that like back and things that start to play up, I swear were from like nine years of just getting belted on the football field. Like it's intense and your body would shatter if you got hit at that speed now. But running full pelt into each other, you know, I got, I'm getting two concussions,
所以我坐在沙发上无所事事了八周，我想，我不想冒不再冲浪的风险。然后就放弃了。NFL橄榄球里一定有很多肩膀脱臼。我现在所有的伤，比如背部和开始出现问题的地方，我发誓都是因为九年里在橄榄球场上被撞击造成的。就像它很激烈，如果你现在以那种速度被撞，你的身体会粉碎。但全速冲向彼此，你知道，我，我得了两次脑震荡，
when I was like 14, 15. I remember going to Australia, going to Melbourne and seeing a, going to an NFL match, and just watching and just seeing like the pure athleticism of these guys, running, kicking, catching, tackling, all of them, just incredible athletes. It's amazing.
当我14、15岁的时候。我记得去澳大利亚，去墨尔本，看一场NFL比赛，只是看着，看到这些家伙的纯粹运动能力，奔跑、踢球、接球、擒抱，所有这些，都是令人难以置信的运动员。太神奇了。
Yeah, it's wild. Hey, so I'm still just in awe of your, just general manhood and exposure to elements and things like that. So down there in Australia, you've got the snakes, you got the spiders, you got the sharks. When you're surfing, have you ever seen a dorsal fin? And when you were out back just running around with your motorcycles and pop guns and shit,
是的，太疯狂了。嘿，所以我仍然对你的，只是普遍的男子气概和对元素和类似事物的接触感到敬畏。所以在澳大利亚，你有蛇，你有蜘蛛，你有鲨鱼。当你冲浪时，你见过背鳍吗？当你还在外面骑摩托车、玩气枪之类的东西时，
did you ever see any of the snakes or spiders or things like that? Oh, yeah. Yeah. When I first moved to Byron Bay, there was a string of shark attacks, two deaths, and then one guy survived in the space of two weeks, one out the front of my house and one to 10 minutes south of me. and five minutes north. And I was like, where have I moved to?
你见过蛇或蜘蛛之类的东西吗？哦，是的。是的。当我第一次搬到拜伦湾时，发生了一连串鲨鱼袭击事件，两起死亡，然后一个人在两周内幸存下来，一个在我家门前，一个在我南边10分钟，北边5分钟。我就想，我搬到哪里来了？
What have I done? This is crazy. And then so for the next... She's still paddling out. Yeah, when there was other people in the water. So there was your chances. Your odds. A little better.
我做了什么？这太疯狂了。然后接下来的……她还在划水。是的，当水里有其他人的时候。所以那是你的机会。你的几率。好一点。
Your odds were a little better. But no, there was a period when there would just be choppers, helicopters going up and down the coastline and just like shark spotting. And then they have a siren on because there was for whatever reason, just this kind of feeding frenzy. Yeah, well, that's how they do it. So they fly above and then if they see it. one, there's a little siren from the helicopter?
你的几率好一点。但不，有一段时间，海岸线上会有直升机飞来飞去，只是为了观察鲨鱼。然后他们会拉响警报，因为无论出于什么原因，这只是一种疯狂的进食。是的，好吧，他们就是这样做的。所以他们在上面飞，如果他们看到一个，直升机上有一个小警报器？
Yeah, well, they'd tell the police, and the police would come down with a big speaker and try you to get out of the water, and everyone would sort of sit there and I'm not getting out of the water, and as each guy starts paddling it's like, oh, it's fine, fine, we'll go in. And these aren't sand sharks. The only kind of shark they've got down there are the big daddy's, right?
是的，好吧，他们会告诉警察，警察会带着大喇叭下来，让你离开水面，每个人都会坐在那里，我不会离开水面，当每个人开始划水时，就像，哦，没关系，没关系，我们进去吧。这些不是沙鲨。他们在那里拥有的唯一一种鲨鱼是大爸爸，对吧？
Yeah, they're bull sharks and great whites is the most predominant. No, thanks. What about the snakes? You saw snakes? Heaps of snakes, yeah. A lot of, like, kings. Heaps of snakes. of snakes.
是的，它们是公牛鲨，大白鲨是最主要的。不，谢谢。蛇呢？你见过蛇吗？大量的蛇，是的。很多，比如，王蛇。大量的蛇。
King Brown, like the brown snakes, which is, you know, you've got kind of 15 minutes if you get the anti-venominy before yet. Yeah, and the brown spider is also like the most venous. The red back spider is, and then what's the brown spider? What are you physically pulling a shirt down to your name? I got to hang up. I mean, we see a lot of snakes around our house,
国王棕蛇，比如棕蛇，你知道，如果你在被咬之前得到抗毒血清，你有大约15分钟的时间。是的，棕色蜘蛛也是最毒的。红背蜘蛛是，那棕色蜘蛛是什么？你是在物理上把衬衫拉到你的名字吗？我得挂了。我的意思是，我们在房子周围看到很多蛇，
but also a lot of big pythons. and the pythons are really territorial and keep the bad ones away. And so you kind of, you want those ones around. Python, Python is not bad? No, no. No, they're not venomous, but they're very territorial with the brown snakes and the red-belly black snakes and the ones that are nasty. And so we don't mind having the pythons around.
但也有很多大蟒蛇。蟒蛇非常有领地意识，会把坏的赶走。所以你有点，你想要那些在周围。蟒蛇，蟒蛇不坏吗？不，不。不，它们没有毒，但它们对棕蛇和红腹黑蛇以及那些讨厌的蛇非常有领地意识。所以我们不介意有蟒蛇在周围。
The pythons aren't looking to mess you up. They're not looking to attack. No, I mean, you can, my kids will go and grab them by the tail sometimes. No, no way. How do they do their killing if they don't have the venom? Do they just their squeezers? Yeah, squeezing. Yeah, like mice and rats and they'll just swallow.
蟒蛇不想伤害你。它们不想攻击。不，我的意思是，你可以，我的孩子们有时会去抓它们的尾巴。不，不可能。如果它们没有毒，它们怎么杀戮？它们只是挤压者？是的，挤压。是的，像老鼠和耗子，它们只是吞下。
Squeezers. Squeezers. Wait, go back. Matt Damon, the first time he was asking me all these questions before they came out to Australia. That bitch. He won't even. Then he literally right. I was like, oh, you're fine, you're fine, fine. The first day he drives down the street, gets out of a car, and steps straight on a snake.
挤压者。挤压者。等等，回去。马特·达蒙，第一次他在他们去澳大利亚之前问我所有这些问题。那个婊子。他甚至不会。然后他真的，对。我说，哦，你很好，你很好，很好。第一天他开车下街，下车，直接踩在一条蛇上。
I've been there 42 years and never stepped on a snake. And, uh, and, I mean, this guy's a dummy. He's a dummy. What did the angel do? The angel buy himself a pair of boots immediately after that? Right up to the hip. And a helmet, glove. A pair of white.
我在那里待了42年，从来没有踩到过蛇。而且，我的意思是，这家伙是个傻瓜。他是个傻瓜。天使做了什么？天使在那之后立即给自己买了一双靴子？一直到臀部。还有头盔，手套。一双白色的。
Oh, my God. Wait, Chris, go back to the water for a second with the sharks. Do you still go in the water? Sure he does. Oh, yeah, I surf every day. I mean, people still surf. It's, um, again, it's like all the statistics you hear. But get hit by lightning.
哦，天哪。等等，克里斯，回到水里，关于鲨鱼。你还下水吗？他当然下。哦，是的，我每天冲浪。我的意思是，人们仍然冲浪。这，嗯，再次，就像你听到的所有统计数据。但被闪电击中。
You're hit by lightning. Or driving a car is worse. And I heard one that more people die in America a shaking, a vending machine, trying to get chocolate or whatever, and it collapsing on them. Now, I don't know if that's true, but it's... Sean's got a vending machine story.
你被闪电击中。或者开车更糟。我听说一个，在美国，更多的人死于摇晃自动售货机，试图拿巧克力或什么东西，然后它倒塌在他们身上。现在，我不知道这是不是真的，但它是……肖恩有一个自动售货机的故事。
He almost got cut to ribbons with an exploding glass door. Did you? Chin Chin when they were closed to early, right? I eat a lot of junk food, Chris. So, wait a minute. You know what I love about the Avengers crew? You guys all seem to be having a good time, don't they?
他差点被爆炸的玻璃门割成碎片。你真的吗？Chin Chin在他们关门太早的时候，对吧？我吃很多垃圾食品，克里斯。所以，等一下。你知道我喜欢复仇者联盟剧组的什么吗？你们看起来都玩得很开心，不是吗？
Every time I see you guys. Of course. You and Robert and all the whole crew, you guys are all just yucking it up. And it's kind of fun. It's a good group. It's a good group. And I think, you know, everyone had come into it, expecting kind of nothing and it was right at the beginning of, I guess,
每次我见到你们。当然。你和罗伯特以及整个剧组，你们都在开怀大笑。这很有趣。这是一个很好的团队。这是一个很好的团队。而且我认为，你知道，每个人都进入了它，期待着什么都没有，这就在开始的时候，我想，
a sort of superhero emergence, and each time one of them worked, it was a win for the others and their individual films, but then when the Avengers worked, we're like, oh, we're going to make a second one. And the third one, the fourth one, and the fourth one, and so everyone's kind of pinching themselves that we're still here and it's still working.
一种超级英雄的出现，每次其中一个成功了，对其他人以及他们的个人电影来说都是一种胜利，但当《复仇者联盟》成功时，我们就像，哦，我们要拍第二部了。第三部，第四部，第四部，所以每个人都在掐自己，我们还在，而且它还在工作。
Yeah, it's pretty cool. And just a good group of people is such a fun. You deserve it, pal. Thanks, you really do. Great films. Thanks, you do. Chris Hemsworth, what a pleasure. Thanks for chatting with us today, Mr.
是的，这很酷。而且一群好人真是太有趣了。你应得的，伙计。谢谢，你真的应得的。伟大的电影。谢谢，你也是。克里斯·海姆斯沃斯，真是荣幸。谢谢今天和我们聊天，先生。
Thank you. Tell, when does Cremend, one and what? What's the release? Oh, yeah. It's already out. It's already out. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. It came out when.
谢谢。告诉，Cremend什么时候，一和什么？什么时候上映？哦，是的。已经上映了。已经上映了。哦，是的，是的，是的。什么时候上映的。
When did it come out, Sean? It came out, wait, I have it. February 13th or February 12th? February 13th. No, it's pretty great. It's a character-driven crime thriller, you know. And it has a beautiful sort of suspense, a suspense with through the action,
什么时候上映的，肖恩？它上映了，等等，我有。2月13日还是2月12日？2月13日。不，它很棒。这是一个以角色为驱动的犯罪惊悚片，你知道。它有一种美妙的悬疑，一种通过动作的悬疑，
but also through the dramatic scenes. And the way Bart's crafted this movie, it's edgy. seat pulse pounding from start to finish. It's a sick cast as well. I'll just say one of the greatest, Halliberry, you, go ahead. Barry Keegan, Mark Ruffalo, Monica Barbaro, Nick Nolte. It's phenomenal cast, but it's sort of a throwback to the highest films,
但也通过戏剧性的场景。巴特制作这部电影的方式，它很前卫。从头到尾让人心跳加速。演员阵容也很强。我只想说其中最伟大的之一，哈莉·贝瑞，你，继续。巴里·基奥汉，马克·鲁法洛，莫妮卡·巴巴罗，尼克·诺尔蒂。这是一个现象级的演员阵容，但它有点像对最高电影的致敬，
the 70s, 80s, 90s, but has a contemporary feel to it. Yeah, but it's really cool. I'm seeing it this. But I just have to say, now that I've seen it, and I'm a big fan of the movie, and of course you, that I won't, reveal anything, but when that one character gets in the car, that's all I'll say. I mean, that was really cool. No, I mean, well, you don't know where, you don't know when part of the movie, I'm talking about.
70年代、80年代、90年代，但有一种现代感。是的，但这真的很酷。我正在看这个。但我不得不说，既然我已经看了，而且我是这部电影的忠实粉丝，当然还有你，我不会透露任何东西，但当那个角色上车时，我只会说这么多。我的意思是，那真的很酷。不，我的意思是，好吧，你不知道在哪里，你不知道电影的哪一部分，我说的是。
When one, that one character gets in the car. You know what I'm talking about it. Yeah, I was like, whoa, that's pretty cool. I was on the edge of my seat. I'm stuck to see that. Anyway, Chris, thanks so much for being here. Thanks for having you guys. Chris, thank you.
当那个角色上车的时候。你知道我在说什么。是的，我当时想，哇，太酷了。我看得目不转睛。我迫不及待想看到那个。总之，克里斯，非常感谢你能来。谢谢你们邀请我。克里斯，谢谢你。
Yeah, thank you, Chris. Amanda would say hi if she was here. and maybe I'll make it to the next one. Please, do, Mike. I hope. Thanks, guys. All right, pal. Good to see you.
是的，谢谢你，克里斯。如果阿曼达在这里，她会打招呼的。也许下次我能赶上。请一定要来，迈克。我希望如此。谢谢你们。好的，伙计。很高兴见到你。
Good to say, yeah. Bye, buddy. Bye, buddy. Thank you. Peace. Bye, boy. Splendid. Just splendid.
很高兴见到你，是的。再见，伙计。再见，伙计。谢谢。和平。再见，伙计。太棒了。真是太棒了。
Really good. This is a great guy. This is a great guy. First of all, great guy. I don't know what you guys were talking about. I think he was great. He was great. Big star.
真的很好。这是一个很棒的人。这是一个很棒的人。首先，人很好。我不知道你们在说什么。我觉得他很棒。他很棒。大明星。
Huge star. Big star. And yet so grounded. As you know, you know him a little bit. I hung up with him for a couple days. What a good dude. Humble, kind. Oh, my God.
大明星。大明星。而且还这么脚踏实地。如你所知，你对他有一点了解。我和他待了几天。真是个好人。谦虚，善良。天哪。
Wait, what's 26 minus 11? Boy, that's definitely going to be something else. It's somewhere around 15. Honestly, that actually came out. 15 years. So he's been playing Thor for 15 years. That's a lot of it. I want to go back to the math question because I'm so dessert.
等等，26减11等于多少？天哪，那肯定会是别的什么。大概是15左右。老实说，这真的算出来了。15年。所以他扮演雷神已经15年了。那真是太久了。我想回到那个数学问题，因为我太想吃甜点了。
Is this worthy of recording, Sean? You know, we're on right now. Oh, we still. I'd say cut it, but I'd need the world to hear. that. This is our life, guys. Yeah. Okay?
肖恩，这值得录下来吗？你知道，我们现在正在录音。哦，我们还在录。我想说剪掉它，但我需要全世界都听到。这就是我们的生活，伙计们。是的。好吗？
Welcome to it. Listener. This is, you know, it's free to you, but it costs us a great deal. I mean, and just, you know, time, patience. Yeah, he's, he's, yeah, 15 years as Thor. And then doing all this other stuff in between. How about, how about I threw you guys at the beginning when I said it was Kirk's dad? Yeah, great job, Sean.
欢迎来到这里。听众朋友们。你知道，这对你们来说是免费的，但对我们来说代价巨大。我是说，你知道，时间，耐心。是的，他，他，是的，扮演雷神15年了。然后在中间还做了所有其他的事情。我一开始说那是柯克的爸爸时，你们有没有被我骗到？是的，干得好，肖恩。
I mean, it's sick. Sick. What a bird. I was like, fucking, who is this? Who could have been? This guy, he's unbelievable. On the breast pump information. Right?
我是说，太疯狂了。疯狂。真是个怪人。我当时想，该死，这是谁？会是谁呢？这家伙，他真是不可思议。关于吸奶器的信息。对吧？
No, that is that. I'm, now I got to join my wife on some of these, some of these. Yeah, by the way, I want to know what all that is. Hey, guys, when you have, yeah. Oh, that's it. You're right into it, huh? Yeah. No more wrap up?
不，就是那个。我现在得加入我妻子的行列，参与其中一些。是的，顺便说一句，我想知道那都是些什么。嘿，伙计们，当你们有，是的。哦，就是这样。你直接进入主题了，是吗？是的。没有总结了吗？
No Sean No I gotta go Wait Sean do you have a performance tonight No It's our one night off You're dark Oh good for you J.B
没有，肖恩，没有，我得走了。等等，肖恩，你今晚有演出吗？没有，这是我们唯一的休息之夜。你们休息。哦，为你感到高兴，J.B。
We're dark Yeah So what do you Then what do you end up doing tonight Where does Scotty get tonight out I'm not moving I'm not moving I'm so exhausted
我们休息。是的。那你今晚打算做什么？斯科蒂今晚去哪儿？我不动了。我不动了。我太累了。
That's fair to that's fair to Scotty Yeah What about this afternoon Well we might Take him for ice cream Yes or no But you know what I've been craving Lately is sushi
这对斯科蒂来说很公平。是的。那今天下午呢？嗯，我们可能会带他去吃冰淇淋。是或否。但你知道我最近一直渴望吃什么吗？是寿司。
And now when you guys eat sushi Do you put, and you know, they come up with a side of ginger. Yeah, and usually next to it, it's a little pinch mound of green mustard called. Well, no, I think a better way to say that is what did the sushi say to the bumblebee? What's up, bee? Aye. Bye. What's up, bye.
现在当你们吃寿司的时候，你们会放，你知道，他们会配上一份姜片。是的，通常在它旁边，有一小撮绿色的芥末，叫做。嗯，不，我觉得更好的说法是，寿司对大黄蜂说了什么？怎么了，蜜蜂？哎。再见。怎么了，再见。
Boy, that was a stretch. Willis sick. He just threw up his hot wings. This is terrible. That was terrible. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
天哪，这太牵强了。威利斯病了。他刚吐出了他的辣鸡翅。这太糟糕了。那太糟糕了。Smartless是100%有机的，由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarf手工制作。Smartless。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。